hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my readers Nathan who is a
newsletter reader and has a website
called ila safety they create personal
alarms for women that are trendy and
chic and their accessories so now he's
wondering how do I get the final push
for that big order so he's got a website
here I thought it'd be good to check out
the site we will talk about it while we
give some advice for for Nathan so
here's the site now it's important that
you realize very rarely the companies
like this get huge orders off the bat
from big retailers so you got to start
small built the momentum keeps ending up
the little guys I know it's kind of what
you started with the boutique kind of
retailer so keep on with those and keep
getting in the price keep the momentum
going so when you start talking to the
bigger retailers you have all this
momentum behind you so I know you've
done some pricey bid on TV you've gotten
some articles keep pushing it out and
keep signing up the little guys as soon
as the momentum starts to die it's a lot
harder to get it going and to get the
attention of the bigger retailers the
next thing when you're approaching a
retailer they're going to look at who
else is selling it right so you know on
your web show you say where to buy so if
I click on that all it says is you're
available across the UK in high street
retailers and online so it doesn't say
you know where it is that you can buy it
it goes to say to find out where to
purchase a product you're interested in
visit the product selector so I click on
product selector right now I've wasted a
lot of time trying to find you ready who
is selling your product so then I click
on this as a product and it doesn't
actually tell me like you promised where
I can find us so you know the more
people have to search and find something
on the website the more frustrated
they're going to be so if I'm a retailer
and I want to sell your stuff and I want
to find out who else is selling it I
can't find out without calling in or
emailing in so I'd switch them around
you have some name stores who are
selling it put them on
here show some brands even on your home
page that shows some of the mob show
some of the media off that you've you've
gotten just again built that momentum
going on as much as you can when you
start talking to the bigger guys it's
rarely a huge order that they place they
want to test it on a small scale could
be geographic location one product line
test it out see how well it works and
then from there they experience so what
you want to do work with them you get
that first small order you work with
them you promote it as much as you can
you tell your audience about it you
drive people to their store you want it
to sell out right as soon as they make a
small purchase wherever they're going to
be selling it you want all of their
products to sell out get some media
around that tell your fans about it
build up an audience if they do that
they're gonna want to do more business
with you right the more they see that
people are coming back ordering on the
small scale they're gonna want to expand
it up by more and more from you and the
small orders lead to big doors so I
don't know how much success you've had
so far if you even talked to some of the
bigger guys or if you gotten some small
orders but that's usually the step
process I wouldn't expect an overnight
somebody sees your product and places a
huge order with you but step by step if
you keep building up momentum you keep
working with the small guys you keep
getting the media you show on your
website where they can buy it now so you
can show off some of the retailers that
you're working with and then you start
making these smaller orders with the
bigger guys focus on one product line
even in a geographic location show that
you can sell out and it's going to be a
success to give them the incentive and
motivation to want to sell more buy more
from you and continue expanding about
your product looks very cool I wish you
the best of luck and hopefully you can
keep us posted as you go with your
progress is very exciting so hopefully
that helped if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below and it
also love to hear you have to think
about the site a what you would do if
you want to leave a comment under the
video and stay tuned for next episode
you